welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and order 66 was star wars most
crucial turning point
originally just a tragic gut punch in
revenge of the sith that
recent star wars stories keep revisiting
and revealing even deeper layers of
heartbreak too the mandalorian this past
season revealed grogu's mysterious
escape from that purge
clone wars final season revealed ahsoka
tano's arc during these events jedi
fallen orders showed us young calcus's
escape and as we try to fit groju
into that timeline and figure out which
mystery person could have possibly
rescued him we now have way more of the
pieces of the puzzle to plug
in so i am going to lay out the complete
order 66 timeline from revenge of the
sith clone wars jedi fallen order and
now
the mandalorian because it is pretty
fascinating to look at how all these
events line up so order 66 goes down in
the year 19 bby
but it was a plot decades in the making
so first a bit of background
back in 40 bby jedi master sifo diaz
gets expelled from the jedi order for
foreseeing the galactics of war and
wanting to raise a grand army of the
republic and after he leaves in secret
he commissions a clone
army with the cloners of kamino and in
the brain of each clone those cloners
implant
a chip this is what palpatine will later
use to activate them for
order 66. eight years later 32 bby
palpatine makes his
move playing the trade federation as
darth sidious and the republic as
senator palpatine of naboo
using that crisis to replace chancellor
valorum now as chancellor palpatine a
surprise to be sure
10 years after that 22 bby the clone
wars begin
between the republic and the separatists
palpatine deploys the clone trooper army
pairing each unit with
a jedi commander this is all while
palpatine begins his corruption
specifically of anakin skywalker he
prods his passions
over his mother and padme shmee ends up
dying anakin and padme are secretly wed
and then throughout the clone wars
anakin also forms a friendship with
ahsoka tano
who ends up getting a pretty insulting
exit from the jedi order
which further makes anakin question the
order's leadership and in clone wars
season 6
fives discovers the secret ship in every
clone and then before he dies he tells
rex about it
planting a seed of doubt in rex's mind
that will later become very important
and that brings us to the year 19 bby
right before revenge of the sith
clone wars season seven shows a meeting
with the jedi council yoda mace windu
plo kun ayla sakura kiari mundi and
dipa bilaba inner padawan caleb doom aka
future kanan jairus of rebels
this is the moment the most powerful
jedi on the council basically spread out
to the outer rim worlds
that they end up on during order 66
which was really applied by palpatine
via dooku via grievous to keep as
many of the jedi away from the jedi
temple on coruscant when that would go
down
on urbana obi-wan saves the life of
commander cody the clone trooper who
days from now will turn on him ahsoka
reunites with anakin and obi-wan
asking for their support to help bokeh
10 re-take mandalore for a maul
this decision comes right as grievous
kidnaps chancellor palpatine which is
described in the revenge of the sith
opening crawl
we see them learning about this on clone
wars though obi-wan mentions
what about the chancellor the shakti has
been sent to protect him but we know
from a revenge of the sith deleted scene
that she really ain't
so they decide to divide the 501st clone
trooper battalion with commander rex
leading the new 332nd
with their helmets painted to honor
ahsoka to help boca tan liberate
mandalore meanwhile anakin leads the
remainder of the 501st in the battle of
coruscant
that we see in the revenge of the sith
opening scene so anakin while rescuing
palpatine in that battle of coruscant
follows palpatine's casual order to
freaking execute dooku with no trial do
it and then after that battle of
coruscant the jedi council still
refuses to make anakin a master he gets
pissed so he goes over their heads to
palpatine who makes him his personal
envoy to the council
pissing off mace windu who says oh yeah
well you're gonna have to spy on
palpatine
us obi-wan and anakin share a warm
goodbye as obi-wan heads off to udapa
and that is where obi-wan catches up
with ahsoka in clone wars telling her
that anakin
killed dooku so now in order to learn
how sidious is playing both sides of
this war
ahsoka needs details from maul mandalore
puppet ruler almec
warns them that maul had a vision about
someone by the name of
walker writes he dies maul during their
confrontation tells lesoka that anakin
is a bad boy and then ahsoka fights maul
it is
awesome and maul upon his capture
screams
but before i continue thank you to drop
for sponsoring this video
drop is a free rewards app available for
android and ios that lets you earn
points when you shop play games or take
surveys and then redeem those points for
rewards
download the app and create an account
link a credit card or a debit card
to the app to maximize your point
earnings on exclusive offers and receive
personalized recommendations
shop through the app at over 300 brands
like home depot walmart
walmart grocery or nike i really like
the door dash steel that they have
i use doordash a lot and when i connect
through drop i earn points that i can
redeem for rewards like this
10 amazon gift card like when i spend
money i get essentially money back it
really is just as simple as tap
shop earn and redeem double dip on
savings and be confident you're getting
the best deals by using drop whenever
you
shop you can splurge without that
sinking feeling get a little something
back every time you shop
points add up quickly so you can redeem
for free gift cards to your favorite
brands like starbucks and amazon
and treat yourself guilt-free no coupon
clipping or receipt scanning
earn rewards seamlessly use the link in
the description to download drop from
the app store or google play and use the
code new rockstars
and when you do they'll give you 10
dollars of rewards once you earn your
first 1000 points by completing offers
on the app
and then the timelines converge in a
real clever way in episode 11 of clone
wars
which dovetails a scene in revenge of
the sith mace windu yoda kiari mundi and
anakin learn from commander cody that
obi-wan kenobi has
found grievous on udapa hello there and
then mace windu tells anakin to tell
this to palpatine and anakin
leaves but then in this exact moment
over on clone wars ahsoka and rex
join the chat i sense a plot to destroy
the jedi
the jedi council would have to take
control of the senate in order to secure
a peaceful transition
i understand your mission was a success
i did my duty as a citizen
not as a jedi
no not yet mace windu goes on to mention
their suspicions of the chancellor
so it's like huh what and then he's like
it's none of your business citizen
and then he leaves and ahsoka asks yoda
about anakin
but she does not share her worries about
what maul told her about anakin's dark
path
a fateful choice and as ahsoka and rex
leave mandalore with maul in tow saying
goodbye to bogatan for now
lots goes down over in revenge of the
sith palpatine reveals to anakin that he
is a sith lord anakin tattles to mace
windu mace windu goes on to arrest
palpatine with aegon kolar
stacy tin and kit fisto the senate
wrexham and then anakin stops mace windu
slicing off his arm
palpatine uses his eyelid
to zap windu out the window and
pronounces anakin
duh as this happens
ahsoka and maul actually hear all of
this go
down it's also sensed by yoda over on
kashyyyk
and then minutes after this vader goes
straight to the jedi temple marches in
with the 500 first
and as he is doing that palpatine issues
to all clone troopers
are you okay activating their brain
chips to
betray their jedi commanders that they
have served for years
and what i love about this is these
orders must have all gone out roughly
the same time because palpatine would
not have wanted any delay between them
so all the jedi would have been caught
off guard
synchronized though cody and rex clearly
got
unique specific to them calls so
hilariously palpatine must have been
doing a lot of these one at a time but
as fast as he could
commander cody execute order 66 uh
commander rex execute order 66 uh
commander code oh
damn it already called you so order 66
goes out and in godfathery and rapid
succession commander cody fires on
obi-wan on udapa kiarimundi's unit fires
on him
on mygeeto plo [ __ ] gets shot down on
kato nemoya stas ali gets her speeder
bike shot down on saliyu kami
yaoch ayla sakura gets gunned down on
felucia
bye felucia and we learn in the canaan
graphic novel that deepa bilaba
also dies by helping caleb doom escape
now jedi fallen order actually shows a
flashback
of this moment from the point of view of
cal kestes when jaro to paul sends that
order on the ship over braca with just
enough time to take out the clone
commander and help
cal escape we also know that sir junda
was with jedi padawan trilla suduri
and an unnamed rhodian jedi youngling
yoda also
senses this order with seconds to spare
on kashyyyk and quickly decapitates the
clone troopers
probably confusing the [ __ ] out of those
wookies rex
also gets that order but thanks to his
earlier interaction with fives he is
able to resist his chip
just barely to allow ahsoka to escape
and ahsoka goes to free maul to help
distract the clone troopers and then she
researches five's investigation
on a few astromechs to be able to locate
and disable rex's chip
meanwhile back at the jedi temple anakin
goes
crazy later security footage shows him
carving up all those christmas turkeys
every freaking jedi he can that includes
this knee-slapping moment master
skywalker what are we going to do
[Music]
we also know from a graphic novel that
jedi archives librarian jocasta knew was
among vader's victims as he worked his
way through the temple eventually he got
to her
she sassed him that only the jedi
council can tell her to like the temple
beacon
she ignites her saber ready to fight but
he force pulls her into his lightsaber
now at some point during this massacre
little grogu was hiding somewhere in the
temple
at the end of the clone wars when the
empire rose to power
he was hidden someone took him from the
temple
and ahsoka tells us that grogu had many
masters during his training in the
temple
so presumably at least a few people knew
about his existence though
probably not anakin right because mace
windu never officially made him
a jedi master maybe partially to keep
him from knowing about grogu
now back to the timeline bail organa
arrives but the 500 first confronts him
he is saved by the young jedi
zett jucasa george lucas's son jet lucas
and the rest of revenge of the sith
plays out as we remember anakin kills
the separatist leaders on mustafar
obi-wan and yoda clear out the jedi
temple and
surveyed the damage realized anakin did
it palpatine proclaims himself
emperor two thunderous applause anakin
and obi-wan duel on mustafar obi-wan is
the high ground
and again burns just as maul called it
padme gives birth to luke and leia and
dies and anakin gets the vader suit and
now concurrently with all of this clone
wars concludes with a
beautiful dialogue free sequence of
ahsoka and rex fleeing the clone
troopers
ahsoka deciding to let maul escape and
their dramatic descent to the planet's
surface where
they end up burying their once loyal
332nd
some time after this vader will come
across this grave ignite the blue blade
and remember his old padawan
now this all brings us to the mystery of
in those crucial minutes
at the jedi temple who saved grogu now
it had to have been someone in the
temple right as vader arrived with the
500 first because
there really wasn't any warning time so
it could have just been
vader or palpatine but i doubt that if
grogu got into either of their hand
they would not have let him go so that
maf gideon would be trying to reacquire
him five years after the battle of endor
seer junda is also an interesting option
she did tell cal about her escape from
the purge
clone troops turned against us my
padawan and i took several younglings
and we went into hiding
but we didn't last long imperial patrol
was about to discover our location so
i tried to lure them away from my
padawan trilla
she stayed behind with the young wings
and one of those padawans that she
escaped with and later lost when she was
captured could have been the child grogu
in the flashback that we see of seer
from trilla's perspective it's kind of
hard to tell where they are it does look
like the ruins of age at i temple but
maybe not the one on coruscant either
way based on ahsoka's description it
sounds like the knowledge of grogu's
existence was limited to
jedi masters so like current or former
members of the jedi high council
that could mean obi-wan or yoda who did
visit the jedi temple and might have
known about like a safe room somewhere
in that temple where grogu could have
been kept and they could have been like
oh yeah [ __ ] him let's see if he's still
alive and then run over to check
after we cut away from them and revenge
of the sith maybe a memory we could
revisit in the new obi-wan kenobi series
in the works
another theory is that librarian jocasta
nu who
does have the rank of master and might
have been trusted with the secret of
grogu
though as we saw in the graphic novel
she really did not have that much time
before her deadly encounter with vader
some have suggested former jedi council
member yattle
though most believe she was already dead
or at least not near the temple during
this time it's not really clear
what the canon is gonna end up being
with yaddle but i know a lot of you are
yelling at me in the comments she's
already dead [ __ ] i'm just saying
canon gets rewritten all the time folks
the last option that i find very
interesting is
jedi master mace windu whose arm was
severed and he was zapped out the
chancellor chambers on coruscant though
we never saw where his body
landed and as someone with knowledge of
palpatine and anakin's coming attack
it is possible he could have crawled his
way back to the jedi temple with just
enough time to
secure grogu we go more into these
options in a recent episode of big
question go
check it out and comment down below with
which jedi you think rescued grogu from
order 66.
you can support new rockstars by
checking out all the great options on
our official merch store i'm wearing our
mandalorian this is away shirt but we've
got lots of other great designs new
rockstarsmerch.com
subscribe to this channel hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
eddie avas follow me rockstars thank you
for watching
i have spoken
[Music]
you